So we found for European television that you have 20 milliseconds per frame
update. This is an incredibly small amount of time and isn't even the fastest
time strived for by games. If you have a CPU running at say 2.8 gigahertz,
that's 2.8 billion instructions per second. Turning 20 milliseconds, this comes
out to be 56 million cycles for that single CPU. This sounds sizable, but if
there are million pixels on the screen, this leaves just 56 cycles per pixel per
frame, not a lot of time. Later in this unit, we'll see that the CPU usually
takes care of creating and positioning objects in the scene, these objects are
then sent to a graphics processor which is particularly tuned to graphically
display them.